its strategy or creativity more
important so I got a great question for
one of my newsletter readers Paul love
you guys Paul basically has I'm not
going to go through this whole email but
he has a personality test that helps
people understand deeply who they are
and he asked me a question in presenting
his his idea online both strong
creativity and strategy are important
but if you want a stronger signature in
one or the other would you choose
strategy or creativity would love to
hear what you think is I'm struggling
for a strong branding toss me one of
those yellow paper airplanes if you have
time and it will take your direction
seriously the heart thanks Evan Paul
okay Paul first of all the airplanes are
orange they're not yellow I should have
worn the shirt today just for you this
comes down to thinking about your one
word I believe there's one word that for
every individual is a steady stream
through their life if you think about
your friends and your books and and what
you love out of people and the values
you look and others is one consistent
theme one word that flows through
everything okay for me it's believed
that's why you see it on all my videos
that's where I have t-shirts of it not
wearing it today and you see it in
everything because that's my one word
and I believe that everybody should find
their one word helps them make better
decisions because they know who they are
and so they can bring that to their life
into their business you're talking about
strategy you talk about creativity
they're both important how do you find
the one word that's right for you and
right for your company it's whatever you
feel more connected to so you know my
one word is believed Toronto dance salsa
the company that I that I work with in
the salsa business there one word his
family so I got the shirt on a buddy of
mine Richard photographer his one word
is inspire a budding mind mark who is a
videographer his one word is
extraordinary you know Jan use my media
coach her one word is connect so what's
a better word right believe family
inspire extraordinary connect what's
what's what's better
they're all great but they have to be
yours right it's what are you bringing
to the table behind that word because I
could try to go with connect but if
that's not my word that I'm not going to
I'm not going to sell it well right it's
not going to take off it has to be to
whoever is created the word so
creativity and strategy either one can
work but what are what are you more
connected to and I feel you know when I
get asked these questions that kind of
feel like a cop-out you know like you're
asking me a question you want an answer
you want me to give you the answer to
say hey it's its creativity dummy that's
one important to know its strategy come
on and of course its strategy right and
people ask me these questions are they
they asked me about what business should
I start here's a business idea do you
think it's a good idea or not my opinion
on that that doesn't matter because you
can have the greatest business idea in
the world but if you're not passionate
about it it's never going to take off it
will never take off you can make money
in any industry but you've got to have
the passion for you can make any word
work you're trying to promote this thing
online and by the way I want to check
out this test you should have given me I
want access man I want to see what this
thing looks like so i can give you a
testimonial for it but you know strategy
or creativity both can work what do you
feel more passionate about you have to
pick one word that defines you is the
strategy is a creativity which is
something totally different and when you
figure that out let that seep through
all of your branding and all of your
marketing because your goal is to make
people feel something on every
interaction with your business so when
you come and watch my stuff you should
feel believe you should feel optimistic
you should feel confident you get that
from everything that i create that's
what i'm trying to push out through my
branding so what is it for you do you
want people to feel strategy you want
people to feel creativity pick the
stream or is it something else because
you found your one word is actually
totally different you figure that out
popped up through your branding popped
it through every message that you put
out there and people will connect to a
better because it's more authentic
because it's you that's how you're going
to take off belief
for those who watching what's your one
word I want to know what it is leave it
in comments below I want to check it out
I want to hear from you you have a
question you leave it below to make a
video response like this video give it a
thumbs up you want to see more like this
click on my face subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon